hi thank you for the talk i just had a
question about a comment you made at the
beginning
about uh uh transitioning from male to
female or otherwise
yes you've talked a lot tonight about
how important it is to let people
believe what they want to believe and
how the government and
us have no say telling people what they
should
think or what they should be able to say
i just wanted to ask
what's the harm you know if somebody's
going to be a happier person because
they say that they're a man or a woman
like what's the harm in just
letting them do it i'm not in favor of
government banning people who are adults
children i'm in favor of banning because
now you're talking about somebody who's
not capable of consent
right all of our all of our laws are
based on the ability of people to
consent if you're a child you can't
consent
so i'm very much in favor of banning
gender transition for kids
i think that's frankly evil i think
you're making decisions for children who
are not capable of making decisions for
themselves that are permanent and have
long lasting significant and severe
impact
uh as far as adults if you're 25 and you
want to get a sex change surgery and you
feel like it's gonna make you feel
better
you have the right to do it you do maybe
it does maybe it doesn't i mean
the the research on this stuff tends to
be somewhat conflicting but if it works
for you it works it's a free country now
that's really not the question that's
being asked in our society today
because i don't think there are that
many people who are like we want to ban
gender surgery for a 30 year old
i'm not seeing the campaign for that
what i am seeing is a campaign on the
left that says that my child is going to
be removed from my home 10 years from
now
if i don't agree with the left's view of
how i should treat my child's gender
confusion at age 4.
i see the left suggesting that they want
to find me if i refuse to say that a man
is a woman
as a general proposition right if i say
that men and women are separate then the
left says this is discrimination
or the left is going to suggest that it
has no impact on my business
if i employ a woman at hooters and she
shows up the next day as a man
right like that that does have an impact
on my business right but but the the
the left would suggest well you know you
should you just sort of deal with it
well it turns out that
gender does mean something and it does
have an actual meaning to people outside
of you
i'm not going to go along with the
general societal willingness
to rewrite basic facets of human nature
and human biology and frankly mammalian
biology
in order to suggest that a delusion
is true now if the best thing for the
person is for the person to
to cont they can't change what they're
thinking there's no way for them to get
out of it they want to change their body
so they feel that it is more in line
with what they're thinking more power to
them that's that's their problem and as
i've said before by the way i've said
this a thousand times and everybody on
the left automatically ignores it of
course
i've said that if i were in a room with
a transgender person having dinner with
that person i wouldn't go out of my way
to call them by their biological sex
because rude right i wouldn't do that if
i were sitting right across from them
but if you're asking me in a public
forum
whether a man is a man and a woman is a
woman or asking me to call a man a woman
in a public forum the answer is no